okay hello everyone this is part two of
our discussion about entity qualifiers
um last time yesterday bizarrely I was I
had gone for a walk and I was lost in
the woods when we were talking so I
wasn't I wasn't quite as efficient as I
hope I usually am alright this is part 2
and last time we didn't get a chance to
UM cover some of the some of the
comments that got made in live stream
chat and we'll probably come to those
today okay so let's talk about what we
had figured out yesterday so and I
assume that this is not any different
from what we talked about yesterday here
yeah it's just a comments that were
added and the last set okay alright last
section on qualified value array yes
proposal it's like time series but for
any number of qualifiers and bridge
repairs you're serious right I mean how
would you plot it would let's plot just
work on it there might be asking for a
lot
well then the main thing would be like
with this blood make the decision
between a set of curves or a surface or
a stick this plot implying it's a set of
curves oh no no I mean that would be
well let's try to understand what's in
this thing so this is a mapping do we
have anybody from the graphics team here
no we see if we can find Bret
okay but roughly what this is is a
mapping I'm a little confused by what
this is going to be yes sorry for those
short examples those are more like
development notes in short amount of
time but but the idea is that we have a
constructor that basically encapsulates
a list of the qualifier values that
we've seen yesterday and restricts what
can be in the list for instance the
qualifiers need to be compatible no that
means you have some cut notion of
fairness done okay but let's look back
up here
Atem at the summary okay so let's let's
remember what we have right now all
right so we have right now we have
entered instance right that's the newest
one yeah okay and enter the instance can
take as a second argument a variety of
qualifiers maybe two types it can take
sync that later on get propagated to the
corresponding property or it takes
quantification arguments for elements
and chemicals well this this is yet
another special case when a property
returns function object okay well fine
but I mean it's it's a okay all right
case levitate 50% different case because
there is a property permisos of this
entity type of this entity but it's more
baked in well I don't
and okay I mean this is another case
here these all look like reasonable
cases to me I mean what where's your
case with amount of chemical tell
endoscope here the last example specify
a mass of a substance okay okay so then
I can say for this you're asking for
absolute volume there but I can just say
the entity instance you could ask for
the mass or for the amount of substance
awesome is it obvious that that
shouldn't have a special print form no I
mean it comes back to this to discourage
me at yesterday quantity off in the warm
alpha code is more natural descriptive
of course there's a print form it would
partially work around us mm-hmm for
output okay right um I named as the
nesting problem of this solution issue
that we discussed yesterday
what's the nesting problem
how does we make a solution of a certain
molarity potentially even with the
solutions mixed and then we have a total
amount of them well I think that that's
just the the chemical solution thing has
is it slots enter the instances I don't
think that's a problem
but this will not do because the
molarity is not in qualifier of the
things together it's the combined of two
and because of nonlinearities
you we cannot switch the outer history
no it's not okay I understand but I mean
so here what you will be doing is you'll
be saying the molarities in principle
you'll be saying the molarity list
molarity 1 molarity 2 of each of these
and then the whole object there's not
yet an Pappa into the instance because
what current is not and the instance
would be a mixture bit to be insolvent
and object to be the sauce okay fine so
this is like you're dissolving tungsten
which probably doesn't dissolve in the
holes and hydrochloric acid um okay and
then then the chemical solution would
specify molarities there yeah and then
it's an instance of which says you know
mass arrow 5 kilograms or something
right what's wrong with this computer
nothing for human my understanding form
did to Jason's is it reads very stage um
so I thought I mean to me the only the
only problem was that you have entity
instance where the first argument is not
an entity ok we'll worry about that in a
minute okay okay
only problem with this other than that
semantically it means the right thing is
that correct so I mean it means just
there are five kilograms of the thing
that is the first argument you know
that's right that's fine it's fine
um that's actually to work we need to
carry around density someday that don't
get us that maybe a subdivision I'm
sorry so wait a second
the the molarity is a amount of stuff
for volume and then quantity
specification and mass we need the
density to figure out from birth between
two no I understand that but that's
something that that this was already the
case in this example that Steven copied
over for doing basically non-trivial
properties of the sink we might need it
is an information okay so let's just
write down the okay so this is the
Wikipedia version of this where we're
saying so this is now just an arbitrary
qualified value the one thing that I was
knowing about this and we had this
discussion couple months ago
it is qualified and we get this
additional information that kinda is
partially specified input but at the
same time we lost something
we lost the information about refractive
index so I was actually wondering if we
should preserve everything for what well
in the result like we have the data blob
or something like this like we know like
this one for in three to five to four
don'ts to the wave texture dance 18 but
we have no idea anymore but it is on its
own if you forget the input no I
understand but but many things have
units which tags them but refractive
index happens to be I mean that was a
pressure it will be at least a pressure
unit it would every day it gives a hint
but there are many things like stresses
are measured in pressure units sure so
that could be a result form like data
statement that well data statements of
the entity property entity value well I
mean you know okay so you've you've
pushed this before Tony this idea of
some kind of statement that makes a you
know that that's so deeply you know
semantic web
you know that that's that's basically a
triple an entity property value triple
yes I mean that's just not the nature of
our kind of system to to maintain that's
for all that stuff we just easily make
forward progress we don't store
everything um but I don't understand why
in qualified value if we chose to one of
the qualifiers couldn't be one of the
potentially ignored qualifiers couldn't
be something about what the source was
what kind of a thing it is but let's
take a look here at you know we've got
two concepts here we've got a qualified
entity okay so our concepts are
qualified entities aka ends entity
instance now we've also got things like
entity group which is a different thing
again yes okay so qualified entities and
those come in two kinds of
qualifications they are sub cases of
entities and they are things like
amounts of entities and they're also
things well sub cases of entities could
be date/time whatever now depending on
what the kind of an entity it is there
might be a meaningful amount or that
might be meaningless would argue did say
dated which is the time one is a version
of sub casing but if we would have the
yesterday shortly mention geo placed one
I don't think it's a sub case like it's
a if a person is at a certain place
I feel like it's the same person it's
not a sub case of the bills oh but I
don't agree with you I think that the
the it's sandstone from darkest you tar
or something right
that's a sub that's a geo placed sub you
know in other words if it's still placed
of you know let's say sandstone right
that could absolutely be geo placed to
you know or or actually a better example
is a geo placed isotope that's different
in different minds to him saying okay
yes but that's not what I had in mind I
was thinking you were thinking like we
have a complete entity say typically a
person and we move to person about okay
so look that there's there's the entity
exists boy this is going to turn into
philosophy very quickly the entity
exists and we are describing its
environment that's one case okay so an
example of that would be position in
space temperature could be time
sometimes it's time but time okay that
the real question here is does the thing
change its character as one of these
properties changes or do you merely
moving it around heating it up whatever
but it doesn't change its character so
for example with temperature
ice versus water right ice at standard
pressure at a temperature of 50 degrees
centigrade does that make any sense
probably not what is that supposed to be
that's it that's an excellent example
it's probably possible to get it
metastable in the state sure so so in
some sense it does exist okay it has
probably some very interesting physical
properties
indeed okay what about the Roman Empire
in 1960 does it exist
missing counter features I know I know I
know I know but that's the point I mean
that that's the that's you know
right so that's the issue is is okay so
one case is the entity exists and we are
describing its environment
another case is we are you know the
entity is parameterize abaut
and we are the site I don't think we are
describing its environment we are try
being its environment to get service the
civilized law of thermodynamics we
assume the entity is inequitable iam
visit because otherwise we need yet a
new set of fine fine fine
we are describing it's it's state yes
it's state not the environment State
yeah ok ok we are describing a case of
it eg you know gold in a sphere you know
of radius 5 centimeters right 4 so I
mean one interesting question for any of
these entities is does it exist in the
world
you know we could have a you know exist
IRL queue so to speak I mean we have
fictional characters entity type I
understand yeah
does does Star Trek exist well yes it's
a television program but it doesn't
exist you know I mean this is a this is
a question does it exist in real life
like a sphere of gold the size of the
Sun probably doesn't exist in real life
if I feel point I don't think it's a
sense of aggression because like this
fear of God
what does existence mean like is it
stable with respect to becoming a black
hole or you know it gets a very easy
okay there's another example which is if
I'm taking a a sphere and I've got a
parameter ization of the sphere and I
ask for something you know parameter
value outside the range of parameters
which is I think very similar to asking
Roman Empire in 1960 yeah okay so this
would be you know something like you
know longitude 450 degrees is it just it
doesn't exist as a matter of you know
definitionally doesn't exist okay so go
ahead this concrete one Bob you would
walk because sometimes I know it yeah
latitude 450 degrees I think yes um
maybe this question could be decomposed
in the first step is having an
identifier or minting one and then
finding an objective actually refers to
that it's like writing down an ISBN for
a book that hasn't been printed yet or
inventing a nice view yeah I understand
does it resolved into something real yes
well actually all we can say does it
resolve to something we know about
something real or something we know
about because maybe all we can say is it
doesn't resolve to something we know
about the sphere of gold the size of the
Sun might resolve in principle but it
doesn't resolve something we know about
um okay
we did metaphor any for any
Christiansted rincon you can ask you
about this object potentially I don't
know I mean look at the Roman Empire in
1960 what's the population of the Roman
Empire in 1960 it matters that it
doesn't exist but I mean that's the
difference between computed properties
and looked up all these measured ones
yes but that's a fine line when we do
interpolation yes like ice at 50 degrees
centigrade we might very well be able to
you know extrapolate it's electric
resistivity or something well let me
give you an example I said 50 degrees
centigrade
say crystal structure that's a little
funky but but we could imagine that that
would be determinable all right so so
again what we've got here is a
collection of qualifiers to a thing
usually an entity a concrete you know I
I wouldn't be that horrified by using
entity instance even though there are
cases like this where it is not truly an
entity because it is based on entities I
mean I wouldn't be okay using this if
the thing we had inside was purely
abstract so you're you're saying a
molecule for example is not really based
on entity that your point there yeah
there's what one of our points did Jason
based yesterday and there the question
of existence become extremity hot sure
it's completely unknown so okay so
alright so we've got this notion of a
qualified object and then we've got we
can subcase the object we can talk about
the amount of an object then for both of
these it could migrate to the property
to the property or to the entity and
don't think it matters much does it
therefore the amount there isn't a
natural property like William is not a
property of cold but once I have 10 kilo
of gold I can speak about it for you so
there's a poverty that didn't exist
before how we can deal with that great
now we have a small hot coded list of
things dead okay so this is team
properties that exists for certain
instances but not in general court Iggy
volume four five kilograms of of
tungsten or something
so these are necessarily computable not
necessarily computer properties no it
could be is it will it kill of an
elephant or something which isn't really
a computed property in the sense that it
is well I don't really know what it is
okay so that volume thing so so what you
have is a set of additional properties
to an entity that only apply when the
entity is instanced and I mean we did
this because it fed naturally but it is
not obvious that is a hundred percent
right approach because there are very
few entities that are of this type like
element food chemicals isotopes where we
have this slightly obstructive substance
like object they are like four people it
doesn't apply in any well okay so look
there are there are there are continuous
quantity that continuously quantifiable
things eg substances I mean there are
slightly complicated things like
strawberries for example right there are
individual strawberries seven of them
and there is a certain mass of
strawberries a continuous number what
might not be realizable in an actual
collection of strawberries right but
they paid for the nutritionist thinks
you are probably interested in how much
is in hongkong
wazzle then in 9.47 okay but let's take
money okay with Queen edge you know
thirteen point seven to four dollars
perfectly reasonable quantity in terms
of calculations but not realizable in
terms of coins but so yeah I see
I mean because their unity can just
still convent this problem okay so
another thing that's continuously
quantifiable so you're saying okay so
one continues to quantifiable thing as
units units are an example and time
dates okay okay
dates substances but I think there are
others I mean like like come I mean now
that there's something the middle like
what we had earlier like a circle as a
geometric seeing it it's radius is
continuously quantifiable um right
but I'm thinking about other things
which you might not think of I mean you
see there are things that are discretely
quantifiable like number of sheets of
paper
I mean they're okay continuously
quantifiable then they're also
discretely quantifiable so with other
verbs countable
probably countable I mean okay um yeah I
mean there's even more cans of worms
here like we talked about geo placed and
clearly weight depends on geo position
mass does not but weight certainly does
in by not a big effect but if we speak
about say a couple hundred million years
even on time sure I mean and also the
geo placed I mean you know it gets
really funky right if we're dealing with
them you know well the Earth's
rotational poles presumably don't move I
assume I don't think so but the speed
changes for sure
no it the can of worms if the poles
moved for example is humbling asteroid
for tumbling asteroid you're out of luck
that's specifying lat/long on the
asteroid yep but there's a seed a little
bit too too far off form our main entity
uses this for now um okay but anyway
let's let's okay so the basic point here
is there are lots of ways that one can
so there's quantifiable and there's
instance of all things which is I think
what you've I mean that that's what
you've basically identified previously
right in my opinion disordered main
seeing state currently are subsumed in
entity instance but instant scible
potentially includes geo placement and
time yes
yes because the position could be a
qualifier and there's one example like
the rise time of Mars depends from where
you are on earth for instance okay but I
mean like like the qualifier like for
example Sun position presumably should
be able to take oh boy how does that
work okay this is a function again that
still convinced a problem but this
twenty Sayed moths as an entity has a
property rise time and then we need to
say forbear yeah I understand otherwise
it couldn't say anything okay all right
so you've identified these two things
and and the question is now when a
result comes out for a value do you tag
sometimes you okay so the other issue is
so that that's that's putting things in
now the other issue is what comes out
you know single value versus collection
of values versus some some function
versus something like an average applied
to multiple values etc right also
annotations saying like you know how
much of the data was missing things like
this annotations like what was the
minimum measured temperature what was
the maximum measured temperature all
right so what you've identified here is
this idea of a qualified value which is
not something what we usually do in the
system that is usually I'm not that keen
on this I mean I think time series is a
fine thing but this idea
I mean usually we get a result the
answer is 1.2 kilograms per cubic meter
bloom that's it the only case where we
want something different is when we are
having when we have something which
we're going to compute with later I
think did Brett come here by the way I
haven't heard back from him so and I
don't see him in the participants okay
all right so what I think I mean again I
don't believe in this one I don't
believe in this I think what what I
would believe in is this kind of
you know qualified something like a
qualified value array and so what that
will contain much like a time series so
let's remind ourselves what a time
series contains a time series can
contain date arrow value right date
arrow value etc right and that's wrapped
with an event series or a time series by
the way notice those different concepts
of event series in time series at an
event series is a discrete thing and a
time series has tried to interpolate it
makes sense
yes okay so we have both those concepts
in the case of time and they're useful
right so I mean to me I mean I almost
feel like it should be called something
like data series and the question is how
does data series relate to interpolation
function and things like that I mean
this really is a data series that's what
it's about that's the case that we care
about here there may be this one
modification time is always
one-dimensional it might vary that some
of the qualifiers are multi-dimensional
that's fine
I think a data series you know in
pressure and temperature seems sort of
ok so then what would happen is a data
series so I mean what we could imagine
there is many of the time series
operations being supported so if we
remind ourselves what some of those time
series operations are a lot of things
there's a lot of stuff here and you know
that's not realistic be reproducible for
generic cases well a moving map is
certainly reproducible mean histogram
those kinds of things are reproducible
yes maybe one dimensional case no I mean
look mean is reproducible for anything
it's just the mean of the values
whatever those values are again but 20
had showed yesterday that sometimes the
qualifiers are categorical um
standard and that might be relevant for
things like categorical distribution
because for example we might say per
data series I mean how would we get
given the data series we want a
distribution so for example for four I
would imagine we can say empirical
distribution for a time series we can
presumably say empirical distribution of
the values the true statement if you
know yes we can yeah okay and
categorical distribution is also a
perfectly reasonable thing to ask for
so I think that's a look at two
different sides the empirical
distribution would work on devaís you
where the categorical distribution might
be category give a suspected value of
the qualifiers not the value of the C oh
but the empirical distribution is also
oh I see that's just the histogram of
values different issue which is the the
empirical distribution also the
empirical distribution of temperature
values or whatever empirical
distribution of density values for
instance that's complicated cuz that
that's involves interpolating the VAT no
I'm confused now
um okay so let's let's look at alright
so we've got this notion here um okay
so let's let's go back again to how
we're getting these things in the first
place so there's there's two things
there's okay even for an existing thing
today we could imagine asking for you
know population of Italy right which is
our standard Italy population
now right now we say dated comma all and
that rather hackle a returns a time
series right yep
so in general because it's loosely but
it's not quite little yeah
what's that it's it's very useful and
but it's not a hung up census of all I
feel like no that's right right but so
let's give another example let's say
tungsten and let's say that we say um
density no I want I've got a different
idea this bad name what I want no I
wanted as a property right yep
don't Inc your poverty pauses in this
form okay so let's say that's our right
density here okay and then I was to say
all here what I would want to get out of
that is a data series that has you know
with all of its qualifiers you know
pressure temperature whatever isotopic
whatever it is right the whole story of
this if that makes sense
yes I mean and this would otherwise say
you know density temperature arrow you
know a thousand degrees and that would
then return a number with units so
there's a direct analogy here I mean
this is a slightly hacky thing and we
need to understand what its precise
semantics are I mean technically this
probably can work I find it slightly
unnatural formed a few point it's not a
density data instance it's it's a
tungsten data instance
and as we discussed yesterday so it
should be flexible with respect to
moving the instant ordered ahead fine so
I mean that would be instanced a bad
name but instance of tungsten comma all
density it's fine and that would also
return a data series yes
I mean potentially just fit yeah it's
nearly more like a ver you set like
serious implies to me a certain amount
of Awesomeness there will be in order to
it most of the time unless it's very
categorical by the time we call it data
collection or something it's kind of
lost the game yeah I do now the other
issue is let's say we do this but we
want it to be somehow aggregated across
you know let's say we want the let's say
we want the mean around of these things
you know we could imagine something like
that possibly that
the aggregator so we've got already got
a concept of that but in the case of air
temperature data for example we have
that notion of an aggregator don'twe yes
well we've got these particular oh I see
funk right right so that's an example
where there's an aggregator which is the
same kind of idea as this now which
which by itself is a version of the
current entity value
I see so entity value you're saying if I
say entity value Europe of countries in
Europe probably okay then I say
population which I think will work as a
yep and then I say mean I'm confused by
that okay so now if I were to say for
example there I would say empirical
distribution for example worked nice so
now what I would say how would I I'd say
histogram of that presumably so what I'd
say no I would say PDF of that plot the
PDF of that I don't know for a range of
things
for searching would be nice if blood
would just take words there yes right
same for interpolating functions we
should discuss that right that's a
separate thing to me again I think
that's a separate discussion okay
so what we're saying here is that we've
got this notion of the entity the
property the aggregate or so in this
case what we've got is the qualifier the
value the aggregator the question might
be how that generalizes to multiple
qualifiers how to apply different
educators to different if that makes
sense
yeah yeah yeah well I think that's I'm
not sure you can do it in one go you
might have to do it in several pieces um
let's see okay so let's look what is
this this is how you do it an entity
store yes um okay so let's look here I
think right Russ joins okay this is
another can of worms what's happening
here so this would turn into in our
modern version it would turn into a data
series it's not completely crazy a data
series which says
but that's crazy okay because there
that's a qualifier associated with what
kind of a head of state it was
different thing but then what we said
earlier it's a little bit flexible but
rituals disqualify us but also to enter
the inveterate poverty sure but I'm
saying in the output if it's a data
series the data series here would be you
know start time blah blah blah this is
basically saying with this bag of things
it would turn around and it would say
this association arrow Herald v yes but
this is then an utter can of worms here
because what we'd all Timon tis
something we want to get out from that
data series we will want to extract the
time series of values for example soon
I'm saying so we might be able to do
that by just saying simply time series
and it might just get that out of this
by looking at I mean probably not for
the wiki case but for our own cases for
our own one we know what kind of dates
we have sure well I mean even in this
case we could say extract from um so
it's kind of dimensional it used to
first difference yeah operations on data
series okay so then what we would do is
we would say so for example you might
say time series of the data series or we
might say for Jake's data serious Kumar
yeah neat a projection bad name the data
projection of data series and then with
respect to pressure for example
actually living right we might get a
small problem business like we would
have multiple values for the same point
which anything lady it's not enough
indeed we also probably will want to be
able to select on the right-hand side so
to speak it's for a particular pressure
value you know it might end up being
pressure arrow value of some kind so
this would say project project with as a
function of pressure imply determining
default qualifier values for you I don't
qualify us know it takes all projects
every everything everyone done yeah so
what it would look like the data
structure you get at the end would be a
data series of and this is where Brett
is about to come in because this would
say um I don't know what the structure
looks like exactly it might be a
pressure but no it no because we want to
have multiple ones it might end up being
a pressure value one arrow yeah okay oh
I see that what this has done is its
projected down to pressure yes and if
I'd said pressure comma temperature then
what what I would have got is Judy's a
2d thing so that what that would look
like is if I say pressure comma
temperature it would make chaos in the
desert exactly okay Brett given a
structure like this how would you plot
it what function do we have that that
will take so even even in this case here
presumably list plot could be made to
deal with this this part could be made
to work with that in the second case
you're probably looking at
the list plot 3d list density plotless
contour plots family of things might be
did a bit more involved like that right
hand side might be vector so we might
want to have a steam well I mean I think
in general the list family of plotting
functions
yes exactly okay I mean additionally
there would probably you know we would
probably extend it to like even things
like histogram where it would ignore the
left hand sides and just operate on the
right hand sides
yes yes I think that's 34 but sometimes
we might want a key to get an impression
about the right hand sides the left hand
sides like I want to know like which
gradual temperature values well used yes
well then we'd have to have something
like keys of this or something you know
possibly some kind of mechanism like
keys of that goes to pressures okay
let's let's zoom out for a second we've
got a bunch of comments on our on our
live stream um coming from my study
essay classifying and abstracting over
types of properties continuous versus
discrete bounded unbounded dense ragged
sparse interpretable
ordered measurable and so on classifying
abstracting I see I'm not sure right I
mean we have functions to deal with all
these different kinds of things and in a
sense the question is what are you gonna
do with it and and for example let's say
bounded versus unbounded we don't know
whether they you know let's say I don't
know the height of a tree is it bounded
or unbounded you know I think it's
it's difficult to know this um okay
let's come back to uh so I see said oh
yeah qualified value could be a rapper
that has different visualization like
around yeah I mean it's kind of the
footnoted values thing it's another kind
of worms um
I mean okay so let's let's talk about
footnoted values and whether there's
anything useful we can do with them so
let's imagine that um I mean I'm just so
used the term footnoted it's not a very
good term but I mean I'd say it's a
value and then it has all kinds of junk
here right the represents it's it's
footnote array decay text you know
exactly exactly so the question is
what's the great text and alpha oh it
has qualifications like relation in 2008
gotcha
okay so the question would be could we
generate this routinely as an option for
these functions that it carries along
like you're qualified value thing and
then when you do an operation on it just
blows it up it gets rid of it
so if you say divide two footnoted
things sorry the footnoting is gone
but the division works I mean in other
way how is this different from the
current annotations at least according
to the current ref page I'm not sure it
is maybe maybe that's what it is but I
mean so so let's imagine that we say
annotation okay so let's say we have
annotation six point seven comma blah
blah blah / annotation eight comma blah
blah blah okay right now that's not
going to do anything what the heck did
that do annotation doesn't show the blah
blah blah it just shows the six point
seven and the eight okay but so fine but
it could be the case that there's some
form of the annotation which would show
is a gray whatever it is the issue is
when does the annotation drop off
and that question arises in graph theory
stuff you know the color of when you
when you union I mean this is the
calculus of annotations for graphs right
the question is is there a similar
calculus of annotations for data because
for graphs you take two graphs one of
them has red vertices one of the has
green vertices you Union those two
graphs or oh no you intersect those two
graphs what color are the vertices
answer I don't think if they have any
color at all right now the annotations
drop off in that case that makes sense
yeah so similarly in alpha what we have
is this notion of details where there
are annotations but the main result is
just the result if I'm not mistaken
nodes we do aggregate a source of
annotation for the things that went into
the result boy I'm obsessed with causal
graphs these days it feels a bit like
that that there's a certain set of
inputs that are needed a certain set of
things on which this depends um well the
question is is there a value to having
this footnoted thing and what would its
semantics be so one possibility is
footnoted okay so one possible semantics
is footnoted survives only in inert
functions so in other words if you have
you know footnoted in a list it's a
happy camper right as soon as you square
the footnoted objects they don't they're
not footnoted anymore see what I'm
saying I don't think that's
stupid thing I think that could be quite
useful and it's semantics is quite
simple if we say it evaporates anytime
it's not in a list or another inert
structure I mean so for example it could
be it could be in a in could be in a
graph for instance that will be okay
there's potential problems what about in
notes talk shows Catholics primitives
they I note do typically no evaluation
so who will evaporate them why do they
need to oh I see I see I see
yeah you're saying point of footnoted
yes whatever it says well that would
have to be a piece of code I mean what
does it do for around that case is easy
okay good to deal with that but this is
a very stirring typesetting what does it
do for a round nothing right now the
point of a round will just fail I think
so okay all right so I mean the thing is
is like the graphics primitives there's
one place where we had a rule and it
happens for you know all you know
whenever whether it's pointer circle or
disk or whatever it could evaporate
relatively straightforward but you okay
but you then don't want to really
evaporate you only want to a level if
operated on typesetting disappear it
will stay a nut which is the right thing
it will only only evaluation can
actually do something to the expression
and that's fine if this is squared then
the result will just evaporate the
footnotes okay so you still another
thousand functions or classes of
functions I see you don't not being
happy business
well let's let's explore I think it's
not a completely stupid concept I think
it's a useful concept um and I think it
actually dovetails with another idea
which I maybe don't want to discuss
right here too much but but the other
idea is given F of G of H of X okay you
could represent that as the graph
whatever it is F goes to G G goes to H H
goes to X
yeah that's badly drawn but and I should
have drawn it on the edge labels but you
understand that that's you know a block
diagram ish way of representing this
okay so I have this new idea because
we're trying to we're trying to make
merge a a code and variables version of
neural networks with the version that
involves layers and blocks and the idea
is to have something like this where you
can wrap one of these things in a thing
that's called I don't know notify or
something bad name that basically can
make a version of this in which that is
identified as a node in an evaluation
graph and whether this is relevant it's
probably not relevant to this alright
let's let's come back um the UM
as a question from Andre loaf stream but
extrapolating different time scales on
time series yes we can absolutely do
that we can't do that in general for an
interpolation I mean with time series we
can we can do it at different
granularities
because date objects unlike numbers
numbers just have a precision date
objects have a granularity like daily
weekly minute ly whatever okay let's
let's loop back to the original
questions okay so I think what we're
concluding is there is an instancing
mechanism that probably should be
generalized beyond a name specific to
today's but and there may be some
convenience functions like dated which
the only one that I've seen so far is
geo placed I don't know I never and it
well maybe amount somehow um I mean I
could imagine one more sort of
convenience function um let's see so
dated clearly useful geo placed that may
be too complicated a concept anyway geo
located I'm not sure geo positioned
might be better given that it's geo
position is am is the thing ok so let's
say geo positioned um then something
like substance it really would like to
be a past participle like that um well
let's say you know amount quantified or
something bad name but something like
that not trust form or instance with the
principle also allow for mass and for
you absolutely
yeah amount in a general sense yeah not
in the sense of si well so that way
better would be like substance
quantified or something but it's it's
not the right term it's not the right
term but but anyway that would allow
that would be one of these continuous
substance type things it's not gonna
work because you still you have the ten
strawberries problem because you would
like it to be the same rapper that says
ten strawberries as to say unless that's
an entity group was
thing as to say 10 grams of strawberries
but everything got a problem because
like 10 comma SI unit and 10 items is a
unit
I see okay so and then 10 might just
default to the 10 item case right but I
would prefer items slicers and for food
we have so many of them well fair enough
but there are elephants you know 10
elephants okay yes um
okay so then the concept would be there
are these convenience functions and
there's an overarching function that's
called qualified or whatever it is um um
I need to go in a few minutes if so
let's let's just try and um okay so what
we're even our livestream is suggesting
amounted it's kind of hard yeah
quantified the problem of quantified is
it's because of quantifiers like for all
in there exists who invented that me was
it Frager who invented there no
quantifiers existed as a concept back in
the time of live nets I know who
invented the term quantifier not a great
term um but um okay so we've got these
rappers they can be around either
entities or properties actually not just
entities they can be around molecules
and molecules external identifiers yours
right okay so that's what goes in that's
the thing that goes in what comes out oh
I see I see so what comes out is then a
typical form is something like oh now
I'm really confused but you want to come
out is your new data serious concept I
know I know I know I know but so then
it's okay so this would be qualified
let's say of thing comma qualifier value
pressure arrow blah blah blah comma no
this isn't right this isn't right
because that's a space so power meters
which are not very specified it's
pressure arrow all you could keep the
pressure concrete but temperature might
be okay but so then what you would do is
you would say pressure arrow this
temperature arrow and that would then
return a data series okay this one I
feel like is now a little bit tricky
because now you would have to internally
specify what happens if you don't have
to special value but it's a technicality
yeah I think it's a technical term you
can just error if it's but but then you
know what we need to be able to
represent is you know nearest to that or
something now we might also want to
average over all pressures we might want
this as a function of temperature
averaged over pressures it's some kind
that's related to a comment from last
time they are basically to qualify our
syntax resembles the implicit entity
class syntax and therefore one X right
inside any kind of operator yeah I
understand right
give results like averaged over one
quantity
etc cf implicit entities so what you're
saying is we should think of this as an
implicit entity or possibly an
aggregated implicit entity
so for example let's say I say um well
let's say I say take largest of three
five whatever that would give me the
data series I don't exactly know what
that would return a two dimensional data
series that is indexed by some pressure
values the five largest and for each of
them at temperature temperature series
yeah I think that's right
yeah that's an interesting suggestion
from I see on our live stream is is this
a an operator form
yes
I mean that does raise the question of
qualified with a list which I think
should just work i alright so if this
things are in this edition then this
just makes it reasonably clear this
means yeah right okay so look I think
here's what we should do
why don't you try and sort of clean up
the concept of this qualified thing yes
the data seems I think we have to do
some singing and playing around this
right and what its operations would be
which will be analogous to the
operations of they bloom in
multi-dimensional analogues of the
operation of time series but that should
also be looked at with respect to the
Geo stuff the new geo statistics stuff
which will already have two-dimensional
things which have to be projected in
various ways although in that case the
two dimensions are you know a very
spacial yes so all the examples that
currently return a list of qualified
where you would instead return a data
series yeah right right
um and here this footnoted concept I
think is also worth looking at and what
that would be effectively is in the
outputs one of the aggregators one of
those third argument aggregators would
be something like footnoted that's not
but the basic point is I mean just like
you know to me some physical quantities
it's worth returning there around values
you know sometimes okay so you know this
is a choice of values returned right
and the things we could return okay one
case is case one include multiple values
of other qualifiers of other qualifiers
or or or qualifiers in general
you know in other words you think the
value you know what's the population of
London well
one thing returned its time-series
across you know dates or something case
two is return around return footnoted
what else might you return along those
lines
I mean in principle you could return a
probability distribution you know some
normal distribution or some such other
thing for a few things that might make
sense
I mean particularly in um I don't know
in some quantum mechanical thing or
something like that one could imagine
returning that but those are the most
obvious things to return here where
where these are you know those behave
like a single number um
yeah I mean there's also a question of
how this relates to data set which is
you know the relation between data set
okay so this is a question question
question relation actually this is a
question
relation of data set to data series
because they're actually very similar
in fact maybe dataseries should just be
a data set but normally in data sets
we're thinking about them as discrete
data we're not thinking about them as
being interpret and tabulated can you
feed a data series to get an
interpolation function out of it
well one would hope so okay he finished
saying that pandas already moles
hierarchical time series I'm not sure
how true that is but I think that's a
slightly different thing of doing I
don't know I don't know it but but Tim
we could certainly look at that but but
you know what I think this is actually a
good observation but I think that the
one difference to data set that you only
are objected to was data set would have
the repetition of what it is in some
sense why because data set doesn't have
this dis associated all of our column of
trust values if you go back to the Wiggy
date of all the examples like what would
be the left hand side what would be the
key for the bunt Wensley
some generic key I understand that this
is I mean alternatively alternatively a
better way to think about it might be no
no actually I'm done changing my mind
this whole thing here would be in the
key and these would be the values oh
okay okay I didn't think this way I felt
more like each of them becomes its own
I'm thinking dataset right now is not
familiar with having a lot of stuff
packed into the keys but it could be
for two qualifiers would we just have a
flat long data set no I think once
there's a qualified this one doesn't
have qualifiers this one is just well if
it was look if this was presented as
qualifier and value then this becomes
the key
with two qualifiers I would imagine two
columns that are keys and a column those
values no that doesn't make sense
you
hmm
I think you're early IO the idea of a
very generic or special key yeah it's
bad not bad may you assault or devil or
some symbol name exactly
all right okay so I think we have some
thinking about this um with Demetrius
will say about data set those comments
about data frames being composed of
series um yeah I think I mean it's
complicated because if you think of yeah
okay good stuff
alright thank you um thanks the great I
think I think Andre is commenting on
unstructured time series absolutely we
have that um anyway thank you people
here and thank you for people on the
live stream thanks for the comments very
useful and we'll continue another time
okay